the federal reserve has finally admitted
that inflation wasn't transitory but
they made a mistake and they didn't
quite realize how bad inflation would
get or how persistent it would be
now their response to that 40-year high
in inflation is to tighten financial
conditions they're raising interest
rates aggressively and they're beginning
to conduct quantitative tightening by
selling assets off of their balance
sheet but there's a number of analysts
who believe that these actions are
actually only going to make the problem
worse
in order to understand what this thought
process is you have to realize why the
analysts believe inflation has actually
occurred this group of individuals that
believe that raising interest rates
aren't going to help they have a very
specific view on how we got the high
inflation their general thought process
is that there has been a supply shock
that actually the increase in demand is
not what's driving inflation but more so
the kovid 19 lockdown created all sorts
of supply chain issues geopolitical
uncertainty and conflict like the russia
ukraine war that created supply chain
shocks as well and so those external
shocks to supply chains and
manufacturing around the world that's
driven a very difficult time for
companies when it comes to inventory and
their ability to sell goods and services
now if you believe this thought process
if there's constrained supply and demand
was to stay the same then of course
prices would go higher but i don't
necessarily know if that's the truth and
so let's take a look a little bit deeper
at somebody like paul gambles from mbmg
group which went on cnbc earlier today
and here's what he said supply is very
difficult to manage we're fighting
across a whole bunch of industries a
whole bunch of businesses they're having
very difficult challenges just turning
the taps back on
he then stated that the fed is the first
one to put up their hands and say
monetary policy can't do anything about
a supply shock and then they go and they
raise interest rates
now of course if this was only a
supply-driven inflation problem raising
interest rates would make no sense but i
don't know if you can actually say it's
only supply driven
of course there's undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy we stuffed all sorts
of liquidity into every exotic corner of
the financial system we literally mailed
checks directly to individuals and if
you make people wealthier either through
increasing asset prices or by simply
mailing them money they're going to
spend it and so we have to remember the
global economy is a complex machine when
you layer in macro and microeconomics
and then things like geopolitics on top
of it it's an impossible task to not
only predict what's going to happen in
the future but to even understand what's
happened in the past and so naturally
what we're watching here is that people
humans they like to boil it down to
simple evaluations we want to try to
understand one aspect of the economy and
then talk in a black and white way as to
what the solution is
but the inflation that we're
experiencing comes from supply and
demand shocks yes there have been
disruptions in the supply chain yes
there was undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy this is all nuance should
we destroy demand well we probably
shouldn't destroy all the demand just
specific types should we tighten
financial conditions
absolutely in some situations but it
doesn't mean that we should crash asset
prices across the globe in pursuit of
tighter financial conditions in some
sort of blanket way the world is very
complex it's very nuanced and so it's
going to be difficult for people to talk
about potential solutions because the
solutions would need to be nuanced and
that would mean that we trust central
bankers and people in positions of power
and influence to be surgeons to have the
intricate control and command of the
minutia of an economy but that's not how
it works it's never worked that way and
it never will work that way
central bankers only have blunt weapons
they can raise interest rates or they
can drop them they conduct quantitative
easing or they can conduct quantitative
tightening that's pretty much it
and unfortunately those blunt weapons
you can't pick and choose where the
sensitivities where their reactions in
the economy are and where they aren't
ultimately what we have is a mismatch
the tools at our disposal to handle
things like high inflation aren't
necessarily what we need but they're the
best that we have and that's where you
see central bankers economists and many
others trying to figure out how do we go
and look at the constraints of the tools
available to us and use those to get
inflation down
now the risk is if we get inflation down
and we cause a recession that might not
be much better if you went up to someone
and you asked them would you rather high
inflation or a recession they don't want
either
and so naturally the central bank begins
to talk about a soft landing can we
thread the needle can we get inflation
down but not push ourselves into a
recession i tend to think that that will
be very very difficult for anyone
including the central bankers to do that
would require a very intricate
understanding command and control of the
economy and that's just not the world we
live in
and so
should we be raising interest rates to
get inflation down there's probably a
strong argument that that will destroy
demand to some degree and will help tame
inflation but the question is
is the solution better or worse
for what could be around the corner if
we raise interest rates and get
inflation down but maybe we push the
united states and or the global economy
into recession
was the solution worth it that'll be for
each individual person and family to
decide but ultimately the central
bankers they're faced with a lose-lose
situation and there's a lot of folks
including myself who tend to think that
the free market does a better job at
handling these situations that the free
market will be better at self-correcting
than having the intervention from
central banks or any of our elected
officials
now that's a tough ask is to sit by
while we experience high inflation or we
experience some sort of recessive period
but as we've seen time and time and time
again
intervention in the markets especially
around the cost of capital and or
quantitative easing and tightening
it ends up diluting all sorts of aspects
of the market like asset prices and it
ends up mitigating short-term pain at
the expense of long-term problems
the high inflation we're experiencing
right now is a long-term problem
that is due to the short-term pain
mitigation that was conducted during
2020 and the covid crisis
naturally there is no right answer
there's trade-offs in life and there's
trade-offs in monetary policy and the
management of an economy
it's one of the great debates should you
mitigate short-term pain or should you
go ahead and solve the long-term
problems and allow people to experience
that short-term pain that ultimately
leads to a conversation around
incentives and it's one that you i nor
anyone else debating it will end up
solving
stay alert out there we're going into
some pretty crazy times make sure you're
paying attention and you're learning
because at the end of the day if you're
a young person you're going to see these
situations a couple more times in your
lifetime and having the knowledge and
experience that you'll gain over the
coming months will be invaluable to you
as you begin to navigate markets in the
future